a third time it can be a charm and it
can be a signal to let you know that
something should just go ahead and stop
which one is this we'll find out that's
why we're here The Hangover Part 3 so
The Hangover Part 3 is the third
installment of The Hangover series is if
you didn't know from the title the first
hangover movie I never actually reviewed
which is surprising long story short
it's awesome in terms of the whole
blacked out the night before need to
find out what we did the situation that
you don't quite want to happen to
yourself but you want to see other
people go through it and in the course
of that maybe go and it wouldn't be too
bad that actually be kind of fun
hangover did it pretty much perfectly
but now we have hangover 3 and the
Wolfpack is out again we're taking Alan
to get some help because he's become an
[ __ ] now then they run into John
Goodman who of course takes Doug and
he's like fine meet our your friend Doug
is dead now we have our shenanigans
which is funny because it's a really
ballsy move for the separation of the
whole hangover scenario in which there's
no hangover scenario yeah it's called
the hangover 3 but no one gets drunk no
one blacks out they don't have to find
out what they did the night before they
just need to find Chau this movie has
more than a few changes in formula some
of which I thought okay cool others I
was like not digging it one of the
things I wasn't really feeling is a
change of character with Allen's that
Galifianakis his character he was always
like a lovable idiot type type of person
who says something and use pat him on
the head you're like okay you're you're
special so we'll deal with it but in
this one he's actually an [ __ ] he's a
douchebag
they made him that way to make a story
arc in the movie in which he will grow
as a person and that's one of the points
of the movie but you're changing his
character to make a story arc in the
movie and that makes it not fit honestly
I wish there was a hangover scenario in
the movie in which everyone woke up the
next morning it someone would be like
where's Alan and someone else can be
like oh he's dead he died of dysentery
overnight yeah he tried to walk the
organ trail last night and he tried to
Ford the river because he thought it was
like a foot deep and the computer told
him it was a foot deep and he tried to
Ford it and it sunk and then he died of
dysentery the next day like everyone in
elementary school did when they play
that game because that game is
impossible when you turn the lovable
idiot into an [ __ ] snot that's gutsy
that being said it's probably not good
another thing is Chow is a really
important part of this movie which is
fine I imagine
gonna have him in the third movie anyway
the thing I don't like is how they have
to stress him the movie every three
seconds how crazy Chow is I mean I would
buy the fact that Chow is crazy he was a
bit nuts in the first hangover movie
just have him act a little strange and
I'll buy the fact that he's just not all
they're doing you know an unpredictable
degree but in this movie every chance to
get they had to say out loud on that
Chow he's just crazy what's wrong with
them Chow was out of his mind that guy
is crazy problem is that starts turning
into that scenario where that guy keeps
talking about how big his dick is their
point you got to just go no it's not
you're saying that because it's not in
the same sense we start feeling like
well Chow is not that crazy because if
he was that crazy you wouldn't feel like
you have to tell us how crazy he is
every chance you get dude I mean kids
just like that hangover 3 did have some
good throw backs to The Hangover 1 you
know you want to see that in the 3rd
hangover movie so that was pretty cool
you can argue that it was shoehorn into
the movie but is the hangover 3 of
course they're gonna have some throwback
to the first one I like recognize and
respect the fact that they wanted to
take a different direction because if
they took the same direction which they
all drank something and they woke up the
next morning then they had to find out
what they did I would be standing here
right now telling you guys it is a
rehash of the past two movies you have
seen it all before so I like the fact
that they were ballsy enough to take a
different direction with this one
however it does lose a big element
that's helped out the hangover in the
past which is that element of we don't
know what happened the night before so
we get to see it unfold with the
characters and taking this new direction
in which case the hangover is now an
adventure movie it loses that element of
injury in the end of all of it I feel
like The Hangover is like the matrix
they made one great movie and it was a
great solid movie that is a good
standalone movie and they made sequels
that never really lived up to it also
the hangover 3 was enjoyable to watch it
was fun it certainly had its flaws in
the end the hangover 3 is a good time if
you're drunk yeah now is a party which
is funny and ironic cuz they hang
and Owens drunk in the movie at all ever
okay so the hangover 3 if I ask you what
your favorite hangover is it's going to
be one that's unanimous unless you hate
all of them so I will ask you between
hangover 3 and hangover 2 which one do
you like more whatever you prefer
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more